man konnte schon so sehen es wird immer
schlechter sind symptome nehmen zu und
am ende dieser kette hat er sich
irgendwann das auto gesetzt und hat
dieses tötungsdelikt begangen
[Musik]
frank urbaniok ist der einflussreichste
und wohl auch bekannteste
gerichtspsychiater der schweiz
wenn die medien fragen haben liefert er
antworten
wir sprechen mit ihm über die ein
glücklichsten fälle mit denen er als
gutachter zu tun hatte im jahr 2007 ist
ein autofahrer bei emmen auf der
autobahn in eine abgesperrte zone von
autobahnen arbeitern gefahren und hat
dabei vier menschen getötet
der 30 jährige täter ist mit rund 90
kilometern pro stunde und 1,4 promille
alkohol im blut unterwegs sein verhalten
auf der unfallstelle befremdete
er ist aggressiv und findet geil was er
angerichtet hat das ist ein fall der ein
beispiel dafür ist dass menschen mit
psychiatrische erkrankung mit schweren
psychiatrischen erkrankungen die dann in
der psychiatrie behandelt werden oder
durch psychiater behandelt werden das
leicht untergehen kann dass die auch
gefährlich sein können
er hat eine schizophrene erkrankung seit
vielen jahren er hat sich bedroht
verfolgt beleidigt gefühlt der hat das
gefühl gehabt dass auf ihn geschossen
wird also ist ein mensch der sehr stark
unter druck gewesen ist die in einer
psychiatrischen behandlung war und der
dann irgendwann auch aus misstrauen
heraus die medikamente abgesetzt hat
dann wurden die symptome stärker
dann hat er angefangen alkohol zu
trinken man konnte schon so sehen es
wird immer schlechter dient symptome
nehmen zu und am ende dieser kette hat
er sich irgendwann ins auto gesetzt und
hat dieses tötungsdelikt begangen
der täter war seit jahren in
psychiatrischer behandlung und offenbar
gefährlich in den 70er jahren hat man
darauf hingewiesen dass psychiatrisch
kranke menschen nicht gefährlicher sind
als gesunde menschen und das ist auch
wichtig gewesen weil es eine starke
tendenz in der gesellschaft gibt dass
man psychisch kranken menschen
stigmatisiert und sagt vielleicht sagt
die sind alle komisch unter gefährlich
und das stimmt so nicht in der masse ist
es so menschen mit psychiatrischen
diagnosen sind in der summe nicht
gefährlicher als gesunde menschen
jetzt kommt das aber das aber heißt es
gibt aber unter psychisch kranken
menschen gibt es ganz bestimmte kleine
gruppen bei denen dann andere merkmale
zu der diagnose zu kommen und die können
dann hoch gefährlich sein und dieses
bewusstsein das ist zum teil in den
behandlungseinrichtungen bei den
psychiatern
lange zeit nicht so präsent gewesen das
hat sich verbessert aber es ist immer
noch ein kann man sagen ein punkt zur
optimierung dass man verständlicherweise
wenn man einen kranken psychisch kranken
menschen vor sich hat dass man sehr sehr
fokussiert ist auf die erkrankung zu
recht auf die behandlung auf die
therapie und dann vielleicht über sieht
wenn es dann eben an gefährlichkeit
problem gibt
obwohl bekannt ist dass er seine
medikamente absetzte wer dies nicht der
zuständigen behörde gemeldet
mit fatalen folgen 45 teils schwer
verletzte aus einer rein fachlichen
sicht müsste man sagen hätte man dort
intervenieren können auch müssen aber
man muss auf der anderen seite sagen die
fachpersonen die damals diesen täter
behandelt hat die hat so gehandelt wie
es tausend andere auch gemacht hätten
weil man in dieser optik ist es ist
jetzt schon schwierig in der therapie
jetzt sind netz setzte die medikamente
ab was ihnen behandlung immer passieren
kann was tägliches geschäft bei der
behandlung zufrieden ist und jetzt wie
man das vertrauensverhältnis nicht noch
zusätzlich gefährden dadurch dass man
noch eine meldung an die behörde macht
uns straßenverkehrsamt man muss auch
sagen der therapeut rein juristisch ist
nicht verpflichtet das zu machen
es ist quasi eine persönliche
güterabwägung das zu tun und aus seinem
bedürfnis heraus das
vertrauensverhältnis nicht zu gefährden
sich zu überlegen wie kriege ich den
patienten wieder dazu dass er
medikamente nimmt kann es dann passieren
dass die gefährlichkeit die sich darauf
baut unterschätzt oder zu wenig in den
blick genommen wird wer in der
psychiatrie landet der ist patient aber
gewisse patienten können zu tätern
werden
es ist lange zeit gar nicht
außergewöhnlich gewesen
das war eigentlich kann man sagen jedes
jahr gab es fälle in denen bestimmte
schizophrener menschen mit bestimmten
risikofaktoren die einen klaren vorlauf
hatten wo man sehen konnte dass
verschlechtert sich es wird immer
gefährlicher
dass die dann tötungsdelikt begangen
haben weil man zu wenig auf der rechnung
hatte hier kann es sich auch um ein
problem der gefährlichkeit handeln man
muss das abklären muss entsprechend
handeln weil das in dieser behandlungs
optik viele jahre lang viel zu wenig
platz hat
aber woran erkennt ein gutachter einem
gefährlichen sie zufrieden
es ist immer eine beurteilung vom
einzelfall aber man kann generell sagen
dass wenn verfolgungs gedanken sehr
stark sind man sich sehr stark unter
druck fühlt wenn dann vielleicht noch
alkohol und drogen dazu kommen wenn es
schon drohungen in der vergangenheit
gegeben hat wenn man sieht es gibt eine
aggressive haltung die es schneller auch
mal zu aggressiven handlungen usw
kommt das gibt ein ganzes inventar von
faktoren an denen man sieht dass das
kein normaler schizophrener ist sondern
einer ode an die risiken in den
vordergrund treten das lässt sich dann
daran abmessen